Hello.
Should be live here.
only 1.4K viewers on software on Twitch
today.
bait a couple of the people on the
Discord in. Let me switch the stream
view over. I think we're good here,
right? Yeah. Okay. So,
so
we need
Let me grab my non secret secret
browser.
look at all of this [ __ ] garbage,
man.
What? What even is half of this crap?
We need to fix that. I I hate having all
these depths.
Stupid Python, especially
Python needs to get out. Needs to not be
a part of Puffer or anything that we do.
stream working
test.
It works.
Yeah. Yeah, it works. We're good.
Mic's good. Yeah, we're good. All right.
CMake is like
I think that is actually just Net Hack
using CMake, though, to be fair.
Oh, hang on.
Uh
Yeah. So this is the soda policy. Check
this. Uh 9. No, is this No, this is not
the soda policy.
Man, it's good to be back to like
actually doing things for a little bit.
Hello, Jess. Just started. Um, I've been
on important client stuff last little
bit and we just delivered a big thing.
So, I have some time.
We had to kind of scramble to get the
thing put together. Timing was very
[ __ ]
We should be good now, though.
Did you uh Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think
I saw that you messed with that paper.
What was the the conclusion?
like is their result good? Is the method
anything?
Why can we not just insta solve
everything if they're doing this [ __ ]
It's kind of funny now actually when
people are vibe coding RL probably some
of our RL tech is baked into the
language models by this point. I
wouldn't be surprised.
Massive delay on chats.
Uh, really?
Wait, no, chat's not massive delayed.
Maybe the broadcast is delayed, but your
messages show up to me instantly.
Is there a latency thing on Twitch I can
[ __ ] with?
cuz that's really annoying.
Huh? I'll have to get this thing better
configured. I really need to do that
[ __ ] All right. Whatever, though. We're
good for now.
Um,
Oh, I guess that is H. That's bizarre.
Oh, whatever.
Broadcast is g get delayed. Yeah.
and no clue when things are visible to
me instantly.
In any case, to answer question, cat
worked fine. Didn't see much improvement
from omni reset. More sweeps would be
needed. I wanted to test with easier to
solve mur
resets improved SPS learning only when
matched with match decision budgets.
50% more train stops.
One checkpoint poll. No.
Interesting.
You might be able to mine that paper for
some stuff, Jess, but just keep in mind
that [ __ ] hypers will produce some
spurious results.
All right. How good do you think we are
at net hack?
Kick the gold. Farm some reward.
I love this game,
man. I've only played it a little bit,
but it's such a cool thing. Look at that
exploration.
Oh, this pulsy rocks. Wait. Kick gold
for farm reward. Yeah.
Try this door.
Kick. Sees nothing. Leaves instantly.
Okay.
messes around a little cuz we go through
this door. Fine, no big deal. We try
there. We kill the noot.
Door opens.
Kill noot. Do we go down here?
No, we're going to get our gold first
and then do we go down? Yeah, we go
down. Okay.
Ooh, shop. We don't care about shop
because we don't know how to buy things.
Fair enough.
Uh, I think we're searching here. We're
probably spending a few turns searching.
It found something. Look at that. It
actually knows to wait and search.
Wait, this policy looks way better than
before,
but it's only.5 better on the score.
I don't know why it's only 0.5 better on
depth.
I also don't know what it's doing here
to be fair. Oh, it's waiting to heal.
Is it? What's it doing now? Of course,
as soon as I say that, it starts futing
around doing nothing.
I don't know why we're waiting here.
What are we afraid of?
Well, the first four levels were play or
the first three levels were played like
perfectly.
Are we trying to farm mobs? What are we
doing?
And then we just decide to go
eventually.
Uh, did we get
did we get a floating eye corpse? I
don't think we did.
We must have gotten the intrinsic at
some point.
Gaspore.
We know not to kill the Gaspore. We're
at negative 1 AC.
How we end up with teleport trap, I
guess, right?
And we get back. Super nice. I don't
know why we like faffing around over
here.
Uh we have not found the end the exit
yet.
Are we farming?
Not a terrible idea to like wait around
and get a level or so.
I wouldn't do this.
I'd at least finish exploring this level
and the previous levels if you want to
mess around and just get some XP.
What is this G? Oh, it's just a gnome.
Duh. I I forget because there's no color
on it. Omni reset quickly because I'm
doing it with naive undo stack which
hurts this PS.
Yeah. So, um n state sets
are going to be infle. If state sets are
good, then we will do it infle and
puffer six.
I guess. Did we run? No, that's a
Gaspore. Okay, we know not to kill
Gaspore.
That's smart.
Ooh, noot
and giant bat. This could be bad.
We might be dead here.
Okay, we're good.
Um, Jess, uh, Finn has jurisdiction over
that box
for a net hack at the moment.
Ooh,
did we just pray to get our HP? I think
we did just pray.
Okay.
Oh, that's Is that why we're getting
smited is by praying too much?
Is that a thing? I never do that.
Okay, we found the entrance.
We go down. We're on D level five.
Any cool things from Net Hack? This is
awesome things from Net Hack. Net Hack
is being really freaking cool.
Oh, we found the uh the exit. Okay,
cool.
Uh-oh.
Careful.
It's fine. Gnome Lord falls into a pit.
It's a wall.
Okay. Do I see? No. No entrance yet.
Yeah, I'm super excited with the net
hack stuff, Jess. Uh, there will be a
big selfplay push soon, though, don't
you worry.
Oh, Mine Town. We're at Mine Town.
Look at that. Our agent got to Mine
Town.
Wait,
Finn. It knows how to shop. It's selling
stuff.
It's selling its food rations, though.
So, now we know why it's dying. It's
because it's getting so rewarded for
money
that it's selling all of its stuff.
It actually knows not to attack the
watchmen.
What are we doing now? Huh?
Uhoh.
Wait, what? Yeah, Finn. This is why you
have to watch your policy, man. All I
did was I just took the run that I did.
I scaled it to four billion steps and I
let it go overnight.
From gold reward. Yeah, absolutely.
But still, it figured out how to sell
stuff.
Senate.
Okay, we're level four.
We're level four.
We go back up. Really?
Actually, I would go back up here, too,
wouldn't I? So, to be fair, I would be
going for Soabon here.
Uh, well, okay. I would check all the
shops first, but it doesn't know how to
buy things because losing gold is like
awful for it. So,
I'm kind of surprised that there isn't a
way for it to just farm reward
um with its like just dropping gold and
kicking it repeatedly or something.
But if there is, it hasn't figured that
out.
I mean this is good gameplay.
Like this is good game play.
Yeah, it's luck of the draw in the day.
Jess
a
sucks.
Okay, we're still zero AC.
Beginning to feel hungry.
What are we doing now?
We're still a little bit fiddly. We
don't have super long-term memory, I
suppose.
Uh, scimitar welds itself to the
hobgoblin. Okay,
this is good. This is good gameplay.
Yeah, go explore the mine levels. Now,
the thing is there's really not Okay,
there's not a reason to rush Mine Town
if you're not going to use the shops.
Except this thing just wants to sell all
of its crap at the guaranteed shop as
quickly as possible.
So, I understand, agent. I understand.
Well played.
This is like reasonably efficient
exploration zigzag pattern.
What does so uh Jess? There's so levels
within net hack. No, there's no way it
does them. They're very difficult.
They're difficult to the point that I
messed up. I think all but one of them,
even sitting there looking at it for 15
minutes.
Uhoh. Uh, I think we just contracted
lyanthropy.
Okay, we're going back up more.
We're probably just looking for gold,
honestly.
Orcish helm.
If we put this on, we should get AC.
We're level five. I don't believe we put
the helmet on.
We should have put that helmet on
if we're uh not worried about buck
testing stuff.
I also I'm not a big fan of the way that
the movement here interacts with our
credit assignment scheme.
Oh, so we stepped on a landmine,
but we're high enough level that to not
insta die to that.
Nomish mines are kind of hard. We go
back to Mine Town.
See, it's not seeing the entrance here
because it's like going super fast.
Uh, and we just got That's the
lanthropy. We're a dog now
or whatever.
That's really bad.
And of course, it's not going to know
how to do anything about that.
So, we die to
probably we die to longtail here because
I believe we do just die if we run out
of health here, right? We don't go back
to human form.
Oh, no. We do go back to human form or
dwarven form. Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Um,
why are we on AC9?
Okay, we el
Oh, okay. We have to put our armor back
on after the lycanthropy. But actually,
we're doing that.
Unless Did we lose it somehow?
Wait, what?
Did we get polymorphed?
Why did we have three health?
Yeah, it's still doing the gold kicking
trick. Um,
oh, we should not be using the run
command.
Oh, wait. We're dog. Okay. Yeah, it's
just the lyanthropy thing.
So, we do find the entrance down. I
wouldn't know what the [ __ ] to do here,
by the way, without having to read a
bunch of wiki articles.
When do you join tech company and make
nine figure salary?
Buffer is a tech company and we do work
professionally.
We build ultra higher sims for
companies.
I much more enjoy doing my own thing
like this.
I think ultimately it will be more
valuable as well.
Okay, we we are back to dwarf form, but
we have awful AC because we didn't put
anything on. We elber a pony, which is
kind of hilarious.
We are trying to put armor on, but we
can't for some reason.
Uh,
does Finn know? Finn, do you know what
this is?
It's saying you finish your dressing
maneuver repeatedly,
but it doesn't look like our AC is
improving. So, it seems that we're
either improperly putting on armor or
something is going on that I don't
understand.
It really wants to put its armor back
on.
It's really trying.
We definitely need to see its full
east strokes.
We are on D level 9, but because of this
AC screw up, I think we're probably dead
in two hits as soon as we run into
something strong.
Uh, we're back to three health. This is
like, right? This is just like canthropy
screwing us.
Alberf,
we're trying to put stuff back on, man,
like repeatedly, and something is just
not working. Let me read like real
quick.
forcibly drops
any worn silver items.
Brain resistance. Hungerless regen.
Randomly polymorph into animal form.
Okay, so this is it.
Lower carrying capacity. Cannot wear
armor.
Ah, were jackackles and were rats will
be forced out of their armor and drop
it. Werewolves will destroy their shirt,
cloak, and body armor and drop any
remaining armor. So, that's probably
what's happening
is we broke a bunch of our armor and
maybe lost the rest of it.
And it doesn't understand because this
is like a longtail event.
praying to your god. So, we just need to
pray to get rid of this.
it's also questionable whether we want
to burn the prayer. I think that if I if
we if it had been a thousand turns, I
would be praying here to get rid of
lyanthropy.
Well, would I actually?
Jackals, rats, or wolves.
So, you can summon help.
Yeah,
this is very sketchy. This is very
complicated. What's happening here?
Back to dwarven form with 10 AC.
How do we deal with this? Do we just
elreath? Yeah, we elith instantly. So, I
mean, eventually what's going to happen
is if we keep doing this, we're going to
fail Elbert and we're going to die.
Um,
we would need This is a very complicated
situ uh scenario though. In order to not
die here, we need to find new armor.
Assuming that we have all our old armor
broken, we need to pray when it's safe
to cure this lanthropy.
And um then we need to put all our armor
back on to get to a reasonable AC.
hits. The werewolf changes into a wolf.
We elbereth him.
Okay, we're just eling everything. I
guess
it's kind of funny that we just don't
care.
Like, yeah, we el. And then we go
downstairs.
Dle 12. This is the very first roll out
I've watched, by the way.
the very first roll out that I have
watched.
Uh, we're not going to be able to elate
our way out of this, are we?
Okay,
mummy is probably too much for us.
Interesting.
We go back up. I think that's a good
play.
Now the problem is we're stuck.
It only el so much here.
Wait, was that the luck stone? Did it
get it?
I didn't see you pick up a luck stone.
Was that it? Was that the bottom room?
If that wasn't Luck Stone, though, that
is very, very close.
I don't know if that was the bottom room
or that was like hidden passage room.
That very well could be. That is deep
enough that it could have been. I have
not gotten there myself yet to be fair,
but I have done so.
My latest run should get here.
It's kind of funny to see how well this
is working.
It's just like, yeah, well, Elbert
everything.
That's a small mimic. That was the room.
Then we must have gotten it.
Double check the VOD cuz that's I mean,
if so, like that's I I want that feature
added though. Finn, can you add the
thing to see if we get a luck stone in
training? Cuz
that's like that's giga giga soda. Huh?
Where are we? Oh, we're
we're getting polymorph weird stuff and
we die. Okay,
that was still that was the first game.
You have to S for a way out of the box
and then look around.
Okay,
see, I didn't know that.
Then I think I've been there as well.
Uh, we're dropping a lot of frames right
now for some reason.
I don't know what's happening.
I think my internet's just being dumb.
The stream might drop. The internet's
just being dumb, I think.
Let's just see
one more roll out.
This one will do faster.
Pick some coins.
live so far. Uh, no, it died on the last
one, but I mean it that was such a niche
thing.
It the lyanthropy killed it basically
or got it killed rather.
Uh, we should not be here. We're too low
health, like too low level to be here.
We should be We certainly should not be
here until we're at least one level
higher.
Maybe it gets away with it. Let's see.
I would really want to be a level higher
here.
Maybe it's Maybe it's right. Maybe it's
just better at net hack.
See
Is this mine town?
Oh yeah, this is really weird mine town
layout. Cool.
And we sell everything. We sell all our
rations. We sell our dagger. We sell
literally everything cuz we love money.
Because the reward is ridiculous.
Yeah. So, we just rush mine town and
sell literally everything
and then we go back upstairs and try to
like loot goblin more stuff to sell.
That's hilarious.
And this is 700. Yeah. So this is like
several hundred step level reasoning.
Uh we still are like not we should not
be here. This is sketchy as hell.
Did we find anything else to sell? Why
are we back here?
Oh, we went back upstairs. Right, right,
right, right. Could
we explore
just loot goblin?
Uh,
wait.
Okay, we found the main entrance down.
then. Yeah, that's what we just did. So,
we actually backtracked from m from mine
town.
I didn't think that would work. That's
nuts.
Uh, it's trained on just one class. This
is Balk.
I don't actually know whether that would
make it worse. Well, okay, if you're
rolling the weak characters, then
obviously it makes it worse, right? I
don't know if it would make it any worse
if you just randomize like Valk,
Samurai, Monk.
Yeah, if you give it Taurus, it'll be
worse, but so will I.
Am I looking at the policy I think I'm
looking at? Like what is this dude? This
policy is awesome.
No, it has to be.
This has got to be the four bill policy
like the [ __ ] where where am I supposed
to go? Right.
Ah, there I am.
That was well done.
Uh, does it have anything to do
This policy is kind of crazy.
I mean, on one hand, we're underleveled.
On the other hand, we are AC0,
which like
It is also you do get penalized for
leveling up in this game in some way,
right? Like in the sense that the stuff
that spawns gets stronger.
Why did we Why were we dropping stuff?
Oh, we were encumbered.
Wait, it actually knows how to manage
encumbrance then.
I think. Yeah, I thought we were okay
there.
So if we get into another bad situation,
we have to pray or elreath.
We elreath.
This is bad.
What's this P? Oh, no. We're fine. We're
fine.
We should probably be healing.
Okay.
D level 9
shop. We're going to sell stuff, aren't
we? Potion, shield.
Man, we really should be using some of
this armor,
but we just want to sell everything.
Yeah, it dropped to lose encumbered.
The pulse is good.
Uh, latest config is pushed, Finn. This
is, I think, the async version, but
scaled up.
But I really didn't do very much. This
is all your work.
It actually didn't even look that much
better on the stats. This took it from
like 9.5 up to 10 or whatever.
But like the policy is noticeably way
better.
Oh yeah, Finn, I think you should change
it. Can you change it from like DLE or
whatever to number of levels explored?
Cuz um I think one thing that's
happening right now is we are not
correctly tracking
when it like goes to the B like it goes
to mine town and it comes back and then
explores it's not getting credit for
having seen all the different levels. So
I think that's why we can't interpret.
Don't reward for that though cuz then
it'll just like start scouting each
floor and not doing anything. But that's
the metric that I want.
It knows to search. Look, I took away
its ability to spam search and it like
it does. It's like I'm going to search a
few times. Ah, okay. There's nothing
there probably.
It's very very good.
I mean, this is already
like I thought we were going to get
deeper into net hack like eventually
like deeper than this eventually,
but with the level of simplicity of the
current approach,
the
very fast training runs that we're
getting and the amount of backtracking
and stuff, I did not think we would get
this result.
This is above my expectations already.
I do still think that we need to get
more into the uh the main like the game.
There are a lot of different ways we can
do that, but as far as the raw stuff I'm
seeing it do, this is already very good.
We definitely want to push this though
cuz like I mean this is this is the type
of thing where posting a good result on
net hack without having to really do
much other than like you know format OBS
format rewards maybe the one thing with
conditional action or whatever. If we
can just do that and then we get a good
score on net hack in my mind that is
like puffer is ready. Puffer is ready
for whatever tasks we want to throw it
at.
Look at that. We found hidden passage.
We know to search
uh pony. We You're fine. Okay.
No search. Yeah. So, Finn, search 20 was
a absolutely terrible idea. Um and the
reason that that was a terrible idea is
that when it spams that button, it makes
it makes the Sim 20x slower.
So that you are losing half of your end
performance just to that alone. Arguably
the like run plus direction like the go
to direction command until you see
something. We might want to even ablate
that one out.
Yeah, I think Finn you can make however
much of a splash you want to do with
this. For my part, I don't even
necessarily I don't even necessarily
care about having to show this off to
people. I think you can just show it off
however you want. In my mind, the thing
I'm way more excited about is like us
doing well at something like Net Hack
convinces me Puffer is ready for
whatever.
This is like the RL's kind of solved,
man.
Like look at this reward hack. What the
hell? It's perfect.
Uh the hell?
That's Soaban right there, isn't it?
Okay. It doesn't go into Soabon.
Ben, is there a penalty for going up
into Soaban? Is there like a delta level
thing?
Cuz I don't know why it wouldn't go up
into Soaban just to pure like just to
look at it.
You see that?
That seems weird to me. I I would check
that. There's got to be a reason it
didn't want to go to Soabon.
There's like so much money and stuff.
That seems weird to me.
new max depth. Maybe it should be plus
one for new room, man. I don't know.
Valkyrie needs food badly.
Do we know to pray here?
If we just see ourselves dying, then
this is uh starvation.
Any fail of skill issue? Well, it's more
so just that like I'm thinking about
like puffer solving real hard problems
in science and in my h my head like
posting a good policy on net hack as a
learning problem is at least as hard as
a lot of things that are needed to like
revolutionize branches of science.
Uh, you can at least poke your head in
there and pick up a free wand or
something. Ryan,
like this policy is significantly better
than like uh, human players for their
first many games.
We already went to mine town. We
backtracked all the way up to here.
And now what are we doing?
We came back up a little bit. Are we
just I think we're just looking for
stuff to loot Goblin. Honestly, I think
we just want stuff to sell to shops
because it has a ludicrously big reward
for money.
Doesn't pick up the bag. Interesting.
I don't know if it can open containers.
It no longer has access to macro search.
So, it it actually had to learn to spam
the key there. Which actually that's
kind of funny cuz that's like the
Minecraft you'll never ever learn to
break a block cuz you have to hold the
button down. Yeah, it learns to hold the
button down.
Yeah. Finn, like all these things that
I'm pointing out, this is just me
knowing RL plus
me having played a bit of Net Hack. So,
you have full authorization. Whenever
you're like, you know, I'm not quite in
the mood, like I can't quite get like a
really tough research out of myself
right now, but I want to do something.
Play some net hack.
I'm just here watching it like play. I
built this little thing. Well, I
realistically I had Grock just refactor
your thing a little bit so that um I can
just hit space. So I like I can hit
space to have it continue and I can hold
space to have it go five moves a second.
So it's way easier for me to watch it
and actually like tell what's going on.
Wait, long sword. Long sword. Where did
it get a long sword, dude?
Apparently we lost a little bit of AC at
some point.
Where did this thing get a long sword?
Yo,
Finn, also maybe add Excal in. We might
actually get Excalibur with this policy
at some point. Holy crap.
I mean, if we have a long sword in our
inventory
and we're getting to level five, what
are the odds that we just do a random
dip every so often? You know,
it's unfortunately still a one and 30 on
Valk.
I bet you Knight could get it. I bet you
starting Knight, we get Excel with this.
Yeah, you have to dip uh dip uh long
sword in fountain.
It's a one and 30 on Valk though. It's a
one and six on Knight.
I don't think it can. H
way nicer than my system, huh?
I think it's just D, isn't it?
I don't know. Look up the keybind. It's
dip though.
What are we doing in here?
I thought we were going to go back to
the shop to like sell all the crap.
We're kind of like not sure what to do,
I guess.
To be fair, that's kind of how um the
game works is like after a while it's
kind of difficult to know what to do
next.
you kind of just end up killing some
stuff and hoping that you get um some
items sometimes.
What are we doing?
Ooh, okay. That's how we are losing AC
is with the acid blob. I guess
we had AC zero but now we're AC 2.
That is how you die is by losing AC.
So wait, did we not find the main path?
We haven't found the main path down in
this run, have we? No, we have. We do
know the main path down.
Wait, is that intrinsic speed?
Is that level seven intrinsic speed?
Boom. We go down back at Oracle, right?
We know how to go even deeper than this.
food ration.
It also doesn't like to eat corpses,
which is a little
odd.
Oh, hello Oracle.
Uh, I don't think we care about the
Oracle because we can't read. We pick up
a wand. Good.
Um,
dude, I
Yeah, this is literally the most
exciting thing to me in AI right now.
Holy crap.
to make sure this is the policy. I think
it is.
Why is this so much better at eval time
than uh supposed to be in training? You
feel quick. Okay, that's intrinsic
speed. The other one was just decks or
something.
Killer B dangerous
apparently not for us.
Grock feeling compared to GPT 5.6
faster.
Um
I actually I'm way happier using Grock
for most stuff now. Like screw model
quality. The thing spins for 3 minutes
takes an hour and a half.
You can't have a model spin for an hour
and a half and pretend that you're doing
anything.
What are we doing?
You feel weaker.
You level nine.
Oh, are we going to go to the shop?
Why are we dropping everything?
Oh, encumbrance.
So, are we afraid of this enemy and we
want to fight it unencumbered
Bronze plate mail.
We should be wearing that, shouldn't we?
Huh.
Yo, Finn. The reason this thing is not
getting lower AC is it because it keeps
selling its armor because we're giving
it so much reward for gold.
No, those RL algorithms are actually
ass. It's just that like you can't use
the good algorithms on LLMs.
Um, I don't think there's really
anything technically interesting going
on in RL for LLMs. Really?
It's just a big stupid bloated problem.
We sold platinum wand.
A we sell our identify scroll.
This is 10 GP. This is an identify
scroll.
Um the Grock I literally every I haven't
even touched this thing the entire
thing. I was literally using this thing
to figure out what the hell happened to
our star chart. Like
um but yes, when I do use this model, I
think that this is better. Not like as
in it's smarter, but because it doesn't
take an hour to give you an answer. It's
just faster.
Uh possibly not Finn. So, we have to
figure out why the heck it is that all
this exploration is so correlated with
gold coefficient. I think like a lot of
the exploration is it just trying to
hoard loot to sell.
Uh I was try I've been trying Grock for
the last week and a half. Like I don't
tend to hop around with different models
looking for which model is better.
Specifically, the cool thing with this
one was just it being fast.
Pyrolisk.
What?
I have not even seen one of these
things, man.
2d6 gaze.
Well, there it is. there.
Okay. Are we dead here?
Well, I would know how to play this now.
All you have to do is break line of
sight.
We just elith repeatedly.
We just do not care. Huh.
Okay, we leave.
Uh, leaving is reasonable here.
I don't know why we're going all the way
back up.
Do we not want this potion? We do.
Are we going to go sell some stuff?
What are we doing?
I It's kind of fine to just wait around
for health.
Kind of press some buttons.
Yeah, this is sort of the part of the
game where you sort of just start
getting hit by lots of strong enemies
and uh you don't want to have positive
AC
world models. Interesting. Turns out not
really. They kind of just suck.
They're um
just kind of slow. sometimes good. I
haven't really seen it. Definitely
always slow.
And we know that there's a hidden door
there.
I actually don't hate this like go back
upstairs
thing.
It's kind of fine to just go upstairs
for a little bit.
Oh, we went to Soabon.
Ooh.
I don't know why the boulders are this
uh are marked this way.
Wait, we just went into Soaban for a
second to check it out. That's
interesting.
We have our own algorithm spirit. You
can read about it in our blog post. It's
based on PO, but uh the changes make it
qualitatively quite different.
I mean, we're a little bit aimless here,
but I honestly I don't really blame the
model for being a little bit aimless
here. Like, this is
this is like once you finish the very
early game of Net Hack, what do you do?
Right? You have some levels, you have
some armor, you want to push deeper, but
you kind of need better armor, kind of
want a better weapon. There are a lot of
things you can do,
but the decision-making at a high level
is pretty tricky here.
I definitely wouldn't have sold my
armor, but you know, it wants gold.
Given, see the thing is it won't ever
buy stuff. But given that I don't have
any armor, I'd probably try to go get
some equipment in mine town. That would
be pretty safe.
That's also not too deep.
And then realistically, you should
either go get the luck stone or do so.
But if you're not going to do either of
those two, it kind of needs something
better before you go deeper.
I'd probably want to get a digging tool
from the mines.
We need to get the uh the colored the
colors on this. All right, here we are.
We're back at the Oracle.
We're going to pick up I think we're
just going to pick up more potions to
loot Goblin, aren't we?
Yeah, I know. There looks like Oh,
apparently there is a door there.
It's funny. We just don't care about the
grid bugs.
I think we just want to go sell our
potions, don't we?
Do we remember we want to sell our
potions
blog post about puffer like learning
about protein
why oh I'm sorry roboticist don't just
make a lot of simulators hang on I
missed uh I missed some messages this.
Why robotic? You can just call me
Joseph. Roboticists don't make a lot of
Sims. Why are they training world
models?
So, there are a couple things with that.
First of all, they can collect a lot of
ground truth data in the real world and
from a lot of different scenarios.
And it's really dead simple to scale
that just by pouring money at it.
Whereas building a bunch of good Sims is
much cheaper if you have smart people,
but
um like complicated,
I would say.
And uh also like
it's just not really the way that
Silicon Valley operates, man. The type
of stuff we do where it's like, hey, we
can actually make something that's just
good and scales because it's super lean
is just not how VC works at all.
Combination of isn't a super simple way
to scale it, even if there is a way to
scale it. And also like I don't know SV
myopia
current ablation's cooking
6k plus score
what did you do dude
and yeah I'm definitely like it not
prioritizing armor very Add
okay.
I'm going to want to ablate that heavily
with you. But like that the type of if
that makes a difference, that's one of
those things that we need to just fix at
the algo level because that's
disgusting.
I mean, if we're bringing back epsilon
greedy in this day and age,
I believe you though.
Nope. That's good work, Finn. That is
good work. We are at 5k score here
though.
I don't know what policy this was. I I
could have sworn though this was the one
that I trained.
Good fin turn.
Zip co
shouldn't have anything to do with it.
And
it's just you had it right the first
time pushing logits early uh to zero
early in training.
But the thing is like epsilon greedy
kind of screws you long term.
Hello, grid bugs.
These are easy mobs.
Like, hey, anything there? Eh, whatever.
Are we going back upstairs? No.
Going to go downstairs.
Why has it not picked that up? Is that
not a ring?
We are in a
vortex. That's fine.
statue of a jackal
matter. We go lower.
Ah, this dude.
Uh, this is kind of bad.
Oh, it literally is just loot. Look at
this, Finn. That's proof. It came all
the way back down here just to sell its
crap.
sold an orcish helm. We should be
wearing that.
You drop potions.
I don't even know if we're picking those
clear potions back up.
It's still Oh, it picked the potions
back up to try to sell them.
And we have the pyrolist friend back.
Are we going to Elbert? Are we going to
pray?
We're literally trying to shop. We elath
and we die.
Okay.
So,
pretty much
it's trying to loot goblin too much
stuff.
How to convince VCs?
Well, what? You're asking the wrong
question. Why do you have to convince
them? Just build the [ __ ] thing.
Funding isn't even like funding isn't
revenue anyways. Certainly not profit.
More a liability
almost.
Definitely in the colloquial sense.
I don't hate VCs, right? Like there's
plenty of stuff that you can't really do
without investment because it's just
capital intensive. But this ain't one of
those things.
Like why are you getting funding if you
don't need money to do the thing that
you want to do?
Well, this is godly. I don't know what
else to say. This is God. Um is what we
call this.
We all can play the soda net hack
policy.
I spent what, like a little over an hour
watching that.
Well worth it.
Um,
I don't know why it's this big.
Oh, it's like 12 megs. It's not bad.
time to pop up compute. There's honestly
of everybody we could partner with,
there is so much stuff we could do for
Nvidia
um with deeper hardware integration and
Nothing.
Yeah, I don't know what's up with
GitHub, but you all can play the policy
now.
You all can play with the policy.
It's pretty nice.
Going to get myself a drink. Let's
decide what I'm going to do first when I
come back.
I think we let Finn net hack a little
bit.
I have a little bit of core work that I
should be doing.
5C is the current branch.
Puffer five written in C. This is the
entire source right here. It's eight
files.
Arguably, we could delete one of those
as well.
Honestly, let's do the stupid thing
today.
Let me see if we can get the puffer
mascot thing sorted today cuz that would
just be a really easy dumb thing to do
while we sort of just hang out. Let's
figure out if we can get like the puffer
3D ass like 3D asset loaded and all that
[ __ ]
and see if we can make it look good. Um,
because I have to do that before release
at some point.
And then when I have like a full day
tomorrow, Wednesday, whatever, I will um
clean up the rest.
End of summerish bin. So,
uh like what early September,
another monthish. It's pretty good
already. It only take it's going to take
me like a week of actual work to clean
up. And then the question is just like,
you know, what do I want to ship with it
and stuff like that.
I know. I'm pretty chill with this
update.
This feels pretty good to me.
I I'm not super eager to just shove it
out the door ASAP. I don't want to
feature creep it, but I'm kind of fine
just like giving myself time to do
little cleanups here and there cuz I
mean, so many people submitted me big
LLM patches with this uh this update
that like I don't want the final code to
just be LLM [ __ ]
Now, I've been cleaning it up a ton as
you can see by the length of it, but it
just it takes a lot of work on that.
Also, you need to get some sleep.
Oh, I gave you a few things to try with
Net Hack. I know you're going to be away
for most of the week. No big deal. Um,
so whenever you have time to check
stuff, you can check stuff.
Net hack is cool.
I'm going to take a few minutes. Uh, I'm
going to take a few minutes to go get a
drink, do a couple quick things, and
then we will fiddle with the the puffer
mascot loading thing. And the idea is
that we're going to just have like a
simple integration so you can load the
puffer into your ends or whatever you
want to do. I'll be right back.
Let's figure out the uh the current
state of the puffer
thing.
So,
we had this thing
upper amp.
Uh wrong. Uh, I see
we have to go out like this.
this the new model.
I can change the title.
We might do some net hack in the
background, but yeah, I'll change the
title.
Net hack RL works
for now. It like it's kind of awesome.
What are we doing? I'm tired, Jess. I
have done a lot of stuff in the last
couple days. So, we're just going to do
something easy.
Uh, I have had this new puffer fish
asset that we paid for for a while now.
And I got
almost done with getting a tool to load
it into new projects, but I didn't quite
do that yet. We're going to do that real
quick.
Yeah, of course we can see it. That's
what we're doing.
needs a little bit of work.
Mostly lighting.
I love I love this animation. Look at
him.
Boing.
Isn't he nice?
puffer.
All right.
I basically just sort of remember what I
was doing here. And I'm just going to
use this thing to figure out where
everything was because I kind of left it
a mess.
And then basically once I have the
result that I want, I will um
I'll make sure the code is actually
Yeah. So the idea is going to be that
anybody can use the puffer in whatever
end very easily.
So make it very easy to like use the
puffer as the agent in whatever end,
right?
We'll probably have to put some license
thing that you like you can't just use
it to promote some random product or
whatever.
But that's basically Yeah.
I actually do I have unity on this?
We do.
Look at this. This is literally my PhD
work on neural MMO client.
Oh, we definitely need to make sure we
have this guy in uh
here.
The guy that did this for us name is uh
Kenneth Kim.
It took some iterations, but you know,
we were happy with it overall.
Buffer fish.
Why doesn't this not have materials?
Does this not have materials?
Uhoh.
Okay. So, it's not just our lighting.
Definitely.
Yeah, we definitely we need to figure
something out
significantly better for this.
Not just the lighting.
Yeah, Spencer, if you don't have any
reservations about it still, I think
that That's I don't see any excuse not
too.
Okay, I should change this as well. This
title.
like
know how to describe it.
I know flat shading can look very good.
Doesn't it look as good here, man?
This doesn't look anywhere near as good,
right?
play with this. The way the spikes move
looks a little weird for sure.
Yeah, this is so much nicer.
I forgot Finn. This was the first thing
Finn did for us. Uh, internship. This is
super nice.
I need to swap this in for my slide
deck. Okay.
Okay,
I'm just going to have this try a couple
things. I figure this is pretty standard
code. Like there are number of like
textbook standard shaders with a ton of
open source symbols.
Presumably we'll fake the lighting and
stuff anyways.
Yes, today.
We alive.
I think we're alive.
We've just been dropping a lot of
frames.
6KB.
We not do 6KB. We should, right?
It's very weird.
Connection just sucks today.
I I honestly I don't know. Yeah, I did
get Starlink. I might not I might not be
on it.
No, I'm wired in.
This should be
actually what am I wired to right now?
Okay, technically I might not be on the
Starlink right now. I don't know which
one it's prioritizing.
This could very well just be Xfinity
being crap.
If it drops again, I'll just end stream
and then Well, I'm actually I'm ending
anyway soon. I'll fix it for tomorrow.
Are you editing? Nope. This is the new
model.
This is the new one.
I actually can't tell what this Oh, no.
This is shiny.
Well, that's already better.
Um,
curve shape. What do you mean the curve
shape rotating? Oh,
no. I'm fixing. This is a entirely new
model if you can't tell.
so. Basically what we have to do
is uh we just side by side.
We just Oops. Ah, I thought this was the
logo was some stupid Twitter meme.
Uh,
is it
it is
okay. This is our old one.
Okay. Okay, the color groups are off
first of all.
That's going to mess it up.
Let's see if I can get the the base
color to look reasonable.
Replacing the drones with puffers when
the thing is Finn did such a good job
with the drones. Like look at this
thing, man. This demo rocks.
I do see one small visual bug that I
that was fixed in a previous version.
Dude, what is wrong with OBS? What the
hell?